I've been accepted into your culture
your Chief inscribed his name on me wow
well I must get back to repairing my
ship
all right let's get into some Mi the
a-hole questions here Beth says here's
an interesting question for you I have a
straight guy friend who said that he
would be open to dating a bisexual woman
it's not that he's seeking a bisexual
partner just that if the right girl came
around that she happened to be bisexual
it wouldn't be a showstopper as a
conservative and Catholic I think this
is wrong and a recipe for disaster my
friend is not strong in any religious or
political belief so instead of using
that basis to defend my position I said
that if his partner is fond of intimate
relationships with other women then he
alone will never be able to fulfill her
Desires in his opinion a straight woman
can have impulses for other men just
like a bisexual woman kind of impulses
for both men and women he thinks as long
as they don't act out on the impulse
there's no difference between the two am
I the a-hole for telling my friend he's
slightly psychotic for being open to
dating a bisexual woman no you're not
you're not the hill because you're right
and in my opinion in my opinion you
can't be the a-hole when you're right
that's your automatic get out of uh well
I was gonna say it's your automatic get
out of the a-hole free card stop right
there I can't hair this butt keep going
get out of being the a-hole freak guys
what I should say um that's uh that gets
you out of that of that jam every time
now a lot of people disagree with that
they say that it's possible to be right
but also a jerk about it so I realize
I'm a minority there that said you know
psychotic is um maybe overstating the
case slightly I think I think misguided
is what I would say Ian says I'm an avid
gym goer a few months ago I was
approached by a friend who wanted me to
teach him how to lift and to help him
get in shape so he could be a better man
father husband he's a good friend so I
agreed and we've been working out every
morning since here's my dilemma this man
is the nicest person I've ever met he's
constantly smiling and talks like he's a
librarian or a kindergarten teacher
he'll walk up to guys who have just
finished a set and tell them good job
that was amazing some guys are cool
about it but some I can see are starting
to avoid him he doesn't care he'll wave
and smile get openly eye contact dodged
and then he'll just walk himself into
the guy's direct line of sight to wave
and smile again at this point he's
unavoidable and the conversation is
usually how long you've been working out
how can I look as good as you do one day
how's your mom mom
well I'll just take a sidebar there
that's uh I understand he's a nice guy
but that could really be taken the wrong
way if you're going to someone at the
gym and you've never seen you don't know
them and you say hey how's your mom
doing who invited that kid that could
really be misinterpreted so I'd be
careful with that he's clearly starting
to bother people and I'm clearly
affiliated with him am I the a-hole for
wanting to tell him to lock it up and
just be normal act normal
it's my opinion that the gym is a place
where you just get in get your stuff
done and get out it doesn't feel like it
needs to be a social event well your
opinion is the correct one
the rule for gyms you know it's not
quite as strict as the rule for a men's
bathroom look I don't know about women
you know they go into the bathroom
together and it's like a social event
for men that's not the case we don't
talk to each other we don't look at each
other no Small Talk No acknowledgment
um I don't care if you're in the
bathroom and you see like your long-lost
brother who's been stranded on a desert
island for the last three years like in
Castaway and you see him in the bathroom
you can't acknowledge Him there wait
till you get outside so what I'm saying
is it's not quite to that level when
you're out in the gym itself but it's
it's close it's like it's almost there
you don't get unsolicited advice unless
you see someone doing something that's
like dangerous and they can hurt
themselves you feel like you need to but
especially if the gym has become a big
part of this guy's life you want to you
want to talk to him about it the other
thing is people at the gym are are nice
you know I think if you've never been to
the gym before you have this maybe some
impression that people are going to be I
don't know people are going to be
aggressive or judgmental the Planet
Fitness their whole deal is that's the
judgment-free zone but that's really
that's like any gym you go to nobody
nobody cares no one's like no one's you
know paying attention to you um unless
you go one of these gyms where there's a
woman on Tick Tock is like filming and
setting a trap aside from those kinds of
situations but you still want to let
lead people alone basically let them do
their thing so I would uh communicate
that to him have you ever read the fine
print that appears when you start
browsing in incognito mode it says that
your activity might still be visible to
your employer your school your internet
service provider but to actually stop
people from monitoring your online
activity you need to do what I do and
use expressvpn think about all the times
you use Wi-Fi at a coffee shop hotel or
even a friend's house without expressvpn
every site you visit can be logged by
the Admin of that Network that's still
true even when you're in incognito mode
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
that your private online activity stays
private expressvpn is super easy to use
the app has one button you tap it to
connect and your browsing activity is
secure it's as simple as that stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com Walsh YT use my Link at
expressvpn.com walshyt to get three
extra months free that's exp resvpn.com
walshyt from Anonymous hello man about a
year ago I was talking with this girl
but we stopped being friends because we
had a fight we were talking over text
and I forgot how it came up but she said
that she believes that fairies exist
I don't remember her argument exactly
but I believe that she said that fairies
are actually invisible like ghosts the
only way you can see them is if you know
how to see people's auras and she said
that she trained herself to read and see
people's auras so I guess she's seen
these fairies before
how can you prove there could be
invisible fairies you can't prove that
[Music]
explained how uh you would see the
fairy's auras but I didn't really
understand her explanation she started
talking about the Earth's vibrations
during her explanation but like I said I
wasn't really following we then
awkwardly moved on to reincarnation for
some reason that she asked if I believed
in it I said no I don't I'm Christian
she said I'm also Christian but I
believe in reincarnation I asked her how
she believes in reincarnation while
claiming to be a Christian as she said
she thinks God gives you a second chance
if he thinks you have still the lesson
to learn this quickly turned into an
argument she started to get very upset
with me she told me that I was being a
jerk and that I was being too critical
about her beliefs in her defense I was
being a little harsh but my patience was
pretty much gone at that point the next
day she didn't want to be friends with
me anymore because it seemed like I
didn't see the whole picture she then
proceeded to say that I'm a nice guy
with good qualities but I need to work
on myself still
the person who believes in invisible
fairies that you could see with the aid
of the Earth's vibration is saying you
need to work on yourself she's crazy
I'm currently in my senior year of high
school and I sometimes see her on campus
one time we were walking past each other
and she glanced at me and then quickly
looked away trying to ignore me it was
very awkward what are your thoughts on
all this am I the a-hole in the
situation if you were me what would you
say to this girl well I wouldn't say
anything to her at this point like maybe
you were you were a little aggressive in
how you and how you responded to these
uh claims of hers and your only mistake
really was to even get into the
arguments like if someone's talking
about invisible fairies and auras and
everything you're not going to be able
to it's this is a totally unfalsifiable
and there's probably not a lot you could
say you're not the animal it's hard
enough to be respectful of someone's
Viewpoint when you have a disagreement
even when their Viewpoint is even like
vaguely respectable but when they
believe the most crazy the craziest
thing you've ever heard it's it's it's
especially in the moment you can't be
held responsible for reacting there's a
good chance that this is only the tip of
the crazy Iceberg uh with this girl and
so you know it's probably probably for
the best to just move on finally from
Ray says my husband and I recently moved
our four children under five to Utah
from Alaska my husband grew up in Alaska
and his parents are and one sister still
live there his family is very nice but
his mom and him don't get along and his
mom is a big lib she was only vaguely
approving when we had our third child
and outright asked weren't you going to
wait we moved because the extremely long
dark Winters were really getting to me
and my husband makes more money here so
I can stay home with the kids right
before he left she screamed at me in
front of my kids but I'm a child abuser
for disciplining my four-year-old she
went on a rant about time out being
traumatizing that she was smart enough
to use daycare when she was young so she
wouldn't need to resort to timeout oh
real smart oh you know I farmed all the
child care out to somebody else so I
didn't have to do anything that's how
smart I was I was good and told her
firmly but kindly that she was out of
place and that we would be leaving as
this event took place at her house she
now constantly is messaging us from my
husband and my oldest to come and visit
I won't let my son go up without me to
visit because I don't know if she'd be
whispering poison in his ear I know he
really likes her my husband thinks I
might be overreacting but I'm still
extremely hesitant am I the a-hole for
refusing to let my four-year-old go see
her in another state without me she's on
board with the crazy transgender train
for kids so I get so terrified she's
gonna try something insane if you're
wondering I don't know that my husband
would even notice if she was whispering
crazy stuff to my little boy since he
tries to be in a different room from her
when they're in the same house no you
are also absolved you're absolved of all
a-hole guilt
[Applause]
yelling at you and accusing you of child
abuse is uh maybe not an unforgivable
offense but it's a serious offense doing
that in front of your kids so she's
undermining you already in front of your
kids undermining your Authority and your
punishment and calling you a child
abuser in front of your children
[Music]
that alone I you know you would be
justified for not wanting to be around
her at all if that were me family member
screamed at me in front of my kids and
called me a child abuser I don't think
I'd be around that person maybe ever
again and I'm not I'm not saying that
should be the case for you you need to
cut her out of your life completely but
that is the kind of thing that uh it's
just a line it's it's a line you don't
cross so I don't think you're wrong and
then you add in the trans stuff that's a
real concern as well it does mean
is on board with that uh it it certainly
for me it means I know I can't trust
them around my kid so you're not the
a-hole
um all three people may go in peace hey
wait a minute what happened what happens
next come on on let's see the next
episode